there's so much work on your Shadow
Self in Psychology right it's always
like oh get control of your Shadow Self
Your Shadow Self is you know and the
more I I think about it and The more
I've gone through my Journeys and and
all my kind of Evolutions I'm realizing
that most of the time you're the Shadow
Self you it's theor you're the problem
the better version of yourself is
actually out there you're double right
and so I think you have to flip it at
any given moment and it's a good
exercise to do all day long like just a
mental thought
experiment what if I'm the shadow and
there's a better version of myself like
completely independent human like
outside that door that could take over
this life and completely handle it with
no
[Music]
issues
so and good sir thanks for having me
here this is going to be fun so nice to
see you and it's hard to believe this is
I think our first episode in person yeah
which I think makes it more real somehow
makes it more real definitely makes it
more colorful but before we get to the
colorful so chani for those who don't
know who are you I think of myself as a
special in the teenage mind mhm and I
access that by being an author of young
adult fantasy mhm using everything I can
about connecting to young people and
lovers of fantasy through novels so
that's what I've been doing for the last
10 years and for people who might want
to dig into that further any works you
might suggest they start with or check
out website anything like that I wrote a
series called the school for geval for
10 years there's six books in the series
and a Netflix made a movie out of it
that came out last year and then another
book a little bit for older audiences
called be and Beauty which is going to
be a TV show sometime soon so that those
are kind of my two main main things
we'll link everything in the show notes
of course and people should explore your
writing I have explored your writing and
we're looking at some of your writing
your handwriting on cards of various
colors we have orange neatly lined up in
one row yellow and then purple and this
alludes to in a sense your beautiful
pursuit of symmetry and color and also
the format of the show so I had sent you
a note about this fun experimental
format which is five things you're
excited about five things you've changed
your mind about and then five things
that are absurd that you still do or do
and tweak that a little bit and we'll
see if we get to all of them the point
is really just to provide a launch pad
for conversation but I was thinking in
terms of
naming five of three is not terribly
catchy but 4x4 like the piece of wood is
kind of catchy so we could do four of
each of these and then add four people
you are interested in or following or
who people should know more about and
you so delightfully put out these cards
and offered me Dealers Choice and there
are many things we could go to
here
give people some some foreshadowing
there's intermittent pop star cross
collar dating your bull might be gay
nycl LA but we're not going to start
there we are going to start with follow
the flow speaking of catchy so what does
follow the flow mean it's interesting CU
every time I've decided to write a novel
like what my next book is going to be
and I telegraphed this to my agent and
my publisher for a couple years when it
comes time to write that book I'll start
it but it never ends up being the book I
write next ever and what I realized is
that your conscious mind can't actually
solve problems it can execute it can
deliver on the promise of something but
what actually is going to be the next
creative force in your life the next big
decision has to come to you naturally so
it's this idea of the
decision coming to you rather than you
making it and I think especially in
Creative work where it's so important
obviously I'm going to be working two or
three years on a novel my brain will not
let me work on something unless it
decides it so I realize more and more as
time goes on that I am just the manager
I'm the manager of the creativity I'm
not the actual Creator the elves are the
creat they're going to tell me what to
do they're going to be the ones who tell
you what the next book's going to be
they're the ones who are going to come
up with the chapter titles they're going
to do everything mhm I just have to show
up right I have so many follow-ups may I
dive in please all right so I aspire to
embrace this yeah I am like a over
caffeinated Swiss manufacturing plant
manager with OCD and various other
Monkish Tendencies right so I I think
the the manager is kind of running the
Asylum so to speak yes yes on my side
and that doesn't mean I don't have
moments of inspiration but I justify
this by having a schedule and and I kick
out a certain amount over a certain
period of time whatever it might be that
is a superpower that is also a super
weakness right in excess now on the
opposite side of the
spectrum saw this post on social media
be careful folks it's a jungle out there
but I did see a post I thought was kind
of funny and we're sitting here in
Austin there's a lot of conspirituality
here a lot of aspiring shamaness Earth
goddesses running a m and their male
equivalent and this post on social said
a woman who lives in the moment finds
out that that moment is connected to all
other moments and it was like this sad
fake onion article about like not being
able to plan a life you clearly ship in
the sense that you publish books you are
very engaged with the world you're not
just a ship without a sale without a
getting blown everywhere to and fr so
how do you precipitate or think about
inviting The Muse does that make sense
yeah 100% because you could just be
waiting for 10 20
years I think what ends up happening is
that I know what my conscious mind can
do so for instance every publisher wants
me to write a fairy tale fantasy next
because schol for evil was my first it
was abnormal successful therefore I will
get paid infinite amount of money have
infinite amount of resources to write
the fairy tale fantasy I had a fairy
tale fantasy that I wanted to do I
wanted to reinvent Neverland sort of do
a Game of Thrones version of Neverland I
had the whole thing planned out my
conscious brain mapped out over the
course of a year and a half an entire
world while I was writing school for G
evil I would doodle on it in notebooks I
had everything and then when it came
time to write it I wrote the first two
chapters went to sleep and the next day
was like this is this is not my next
book and it came from just this like
feeling the only way I can describe it
is there was part of me that is like we
are not going to spend 2 years
following the wrong impulse which the
wrong impulse was
money easy route right the easy route
and instead this other idea that i' been
noodling around and been trying to give
away to people for the Last 5 Years like
I had told everyone this idea being like
someone should do this idea this idea is
super important like someone should do
this it's going to be like you know it's
not me I can't do this this is too
hard I just woke up and was like okay
you know what that idea let's try
writing it as a short story instead
because that idea is so important and no
one's done it everyone says it can't be
done or whatever so I start working on
it give it to my agent can you mention
the idea or is it still under not yet
okay all right all right all right soon
cuz we're about to take it out
but Meanwhile my poor asent he's he
knows that whatever I say the next thing
is going to be it's not going to be the
next thing so I tell him I I'm just
going to try this idea as a short story
because you know we've sold short
stories before he's like okay that's you
know while he comes up with his next
fairy tale he will do his short story do
the short story must the talent fine
I'll get you your green M&M he's just
waiting for me to come back with
Neverland Wonderland he doesn't care
what it
is hopefully Ever After princes
princesses
you know so I start working on this
short story and I start getting into it
and then I feel that feeling it's that
feeling that I felt with school for G
evil which is I don't care who reads
this I don't care what happens to this
this is mine no one's taking it away
from me I am doing this at the expense
of all other things I don't care what
are the symptoms of that is that you
wake up earlier than normal and that's
the first thing you want to do is it
that I'm making things up of course is
it like a giddy feeling that just
doesn't occur normally in other
circumstances like what what is the
signature of that feeling it's more like
you feel like a cult leader you're like
this is the thing like this is I the
true way yeah like like I am this is now
my church people are going to join you
know I just need to write the thing that
you know like it becomes your whole
personality is it fair to say it's a
degree of conviction and confidence you
just couldn't analytically justifi no
you can't in fact it's funny we took it
to my current
publisher like 10 pages of it and just
the general thing of the ideas and I've
been with them for 10 years writing
fairy tales and they were like the idea
of me moving into kind of a different
age bracket and this is not fairy tales
at all I mean this is as far from it as
possible they wouldn't even entertain
the idea like wouldn't like wouldn't
even go there and it still did nothing
to shake me whatsoever you know like I
was just
like and it's funny because my parents
my agent everyone's like what are you
like clearly your second thing should be
to capitalize on the
and nothing in my body will let me do it
so I have been happy as a clan working
on this other thing and I realize that
it comes down
to what your what you want your life to
be and mine is not getting diminishing
returns on the ghost of a past work even
for a lot of money I remember I believe
it was BJ Novak who's written a million
things very talented very funny comedian
also said whenever he says to himself
but the money is so good that's a
flag and I'm paraphrasing here but in
this particular case so I'm going to Pro
a little bit you can refuse yeah but is
it is it fiction nonfiction Fiction it's
fiction okay it's Fiction it's a fiction
that I would like to happen so it's a
it's a predictive fiction cool it's so
funny cuz when we announce it which will
be soon enough all these things that
we're going to talk about today it's all
it's all there it's like The Usual
Suspects with Kobayashi on the cup wait
a minute everything it's all going to
make sense when we're when we're done I
cannot wait to see how your bull might
be gay fits into
this it seems like follow the
flow has been has been checked now that
seems to this is fun I might I might
have people do this although I'm sure a
lot will not be as enthused as you have
very nice handwriting too so we've
pulled one of the orange
cards does this purple give stories away
tie back it does to what you're saying
it's the idea of when I get a lot of big
ideas and I will not write a book until
I've had the idea for at least 3 years
like it has to stay with me for 3 years
because it's going to take me that long
to write promote take it out and I need
to be sure that it's not going to
suddenly you know be a short-term
relationship and it feels also like it's
Timeless then if it lasts three years
it's made it through most of a
presidential Administration it's it's
made it through all the ups and downs I
feel like it's going to last and so
first thing I do when I get a big idea
that I'm really excited about is I start
to tell everybody I just I'm like
someone should do this I tell my my
writer friends I tell you know anybody
I'm just like sometimes I'll just have
meetings with Hollywood companies about
you know I don't know adopting other
work or stuff like that I'm doing it
really to just like be like someone
should do this idea and sometimes it
gets picked up and they'll give it to
someone else or you know there's many
times where I've had ideas for something
and someone has has kind of done that
version of it but if no one takes it
then after a few years sometimes it's so
strong that that's when I do it so you
know I do know of one other person in my
life friend named Kevin Kelly I don't
know if you know this name Boulder jet
has an amazing Amish style beard despite
the fact that he is an incredibly
accurate futurist predicting he's more
than that but he's very good at
predicting Trends and upcoming
development he tries to give away all of
his ideas yeah it's like you know and I
don't want to speak for him but in a
sense it's in the hopes that other
people will do the work yes of
implementing those it's totally selfish
it's not a generous thing at all it's
this would be great do it for my
entertain like so I can see it realize
you know because there's only so many
things I'm going to be able to do but I
just like I'm jealous of songwriters who
if they have a great idea they they make
their one song you know what I mean like
this is every time I have a big idea
it's a couple years you know this might
seem like a silly question but how do
you distinguish between ideas that
people won't pick up because they're bad
ideas versus ideas people won't pick up
because for whatever reason you are
uniquely suited to looking through the
prism and seeing something they don't
see you get what I mean right if you
were like I'm going to start a waste
management company in
Tuscaloosa and people are like uh I'm
not going to do that that is
fundamentally different
from what you're describing yeah I
always say the test is can someone else
do it so that's when I have the idea I'm
always like sure someone else can do
this but then
if they don't and time goes on and I
start to see this is what happened with
this idea CU When I first had it a few
years ago I thought I'm I don't know how
to do that it's too hard it's just not
in my wheelhouse and as the years went
by little by little I started to be like
well what if I I could do this and this
place to my strength I move this around
I start to see the and then then all of
a sudden you realize you're ready you
know what I mean so I think it's about
can you do it like school for an evil
came out at a time where that year there
were eight other books about magic
schools because it had been 10 years
since Harry Potter and it felt like 10
years later the floodgates open and
everyone was like now all the
narcissists who think they can compete
with JK Rowling are ready to show their
Wares and so an agent was frantic the
publisher was nervous like everyone was
nervous because there were much bigger
books like I think Chris kulur who was
on Glee had one and Mattel was putting
one out called Ever After High which
Ever After High schf evil like it just
they were so similar
and I was never worried cuz I'm like
mine is so weird it's so strange it's
like it's just so uniquely me like I
just knew there wasn't going to be I'm
like maybe mine will be a total flop but
whoever reads it will never compare it
to any of those others you know and that
I was confident in so I think that's I
just know that I just have a very
strange way of Storytelling because it's
just mine I don't know how to follow
other people's
things so number one we'll catch up over
dinner about this but I am actually in a
very similar position right now I have a
writing project my first book in 6 to S
years I can't talk about it right now
and I tried to [__] give it away
forever and it's going to be it didn't
work it didn't work it didn't work and
then a few close friends who knew about
it kept asking me for it who I thought
were going to help me do it yeah and I
was like [__] okay let me take another
look at it and then I took another look
at it and I was like oh I think I'm
ready yeah that I wasn't ready that's it
you weren't ready I wasn't ready you
weren't ready but now I looked down I
was like oh I think I'm ready and that's
uncanny first of all and I'm God I want
to I can't wait until dinner anyway so
there's that second thing that what you
said reminded me of is there's a very
famous Brazilian jiu-jitsu competitor
named Marcelo Garcia and last I checked
he's nine time maybe 10 time world
champion and for at least I would say
the better part of a decade and the
sport has evolved a lot so things may
have changed but he was considered the
greatest of all
time and that was uncontroversial yeah
he was so successful he was so uniquely
himself some techniques he
pioneered and he would record a lot of
his training footage and practice
footage sparring footage even when he
was was 6 months away from the world
championships and he would make it
available online and people found this
mystifying yeah because that is very
rarely done and the most common response
was why would you do that it allows your
competitors to prepare for you right and
his response and I'm paraphrasing but
it's pretty close because my friend coof
founded Jiu-Jitsu school with him so I
got to spend some time around him was
this is my game if someone wants to step
into my
game then like I am the best suited so
interesting to win my game now there are
a million different ways that could be
confusing but it's I found it odd enough
that I sat with it and uh in a sense
it's like by giving away your
ideas you're using it selfishly number
one to get more ideas than you could
shoulder into the world hopefully if
people pick it up and then and secondly
you're filtering to what is uniquely
your own where you have this
differentiator which is also not to view
anything Zero Sum but huge competitive
Advantage well the other thing that was
interesting that helped me the most and
I wish this on every young writer
anytime I did something for money or
something that wasn't 100% like me that
someone hired me to do they all fell
apart like without fail none of it ever
came out so there not a single thing out
there in the world by me that was a
mercenary job I mean I took them in my
20s and 30s it just they never made it
there so I think that was kind of the
that was sort of like the world kind of
telling because it happens so many times
at least 10 times so after that I just
learned like we're not doing this like
even to the point of I'll get in trouble
for talking about this story but who
cares yeah DC Comics hired me to do a
short story for them and everyone like
in my life every male thought like
forget what you've done before this
20page thing you're doing for DC Comics
means you've arrived M and I'm like okay
thanks and so I go through the process
with them it's a nightmare because it
just you know they're making changes to
the character they're just moving things
around because it's the DC machine or
whatever and I you know I spend six
months on it just you know I'm obviously
doing my own own work at the same time
but going through it the whole time I'm
thinking
this is getting further and further away
from me you know to the point of okay
I'll take the check and whatever and
then at the last second like it all
fizzled like the editorial didn't
approve of this and mooved this and the
whole thing just went poof right as it
was about to print the art was already
done everything and I was like I
remember my poor bagard agent was like
what and I was like thank God you know
like it kept the theme that narrative in
my life complete had that it would have
been the first time and the fact that it
went up completely in Smoke on its own
accord was I think the universe being
like you are on a frequency and we will
help you when you get off it so as long
back to follow the flow as long as I
follow that flow everything's going to
be okay so follow the flow give stories
away right at first glance it might seem
like some kind of poetic artist a effect
but it's intensely practical right like
intensely practical and so what I'm
going to do just because is a new game
that we're playing and I want to take a
photograph from the top when we're done
with this of these cards I'm going to
turn this over
Perfect all right so I feel like we
should go to a different category just
for the fun of it you know what I I feel
like I'm I'm buing the lead so your bull
might be gay what's the story here and
it's it's in quotation marks which is I
told you when we stand out I told you
that none of these are euphemisms right
none of these are T so this is the story
so um
I lived in New York for 22 years I now
live in St Louis I moved there for love
for my partner who is a farmer MH and
lives on a goat and cattle farm of his
own and I go there every weekend and
spend you know three or four days there
and so I'm that annoying person who
drops in every weekend and has thoughts
about what he's been working on all week
so anyway he's got I think the
helicopter partner helicopter farmer
from the city helicop Farm been anywhere
near a farm who has thoughts all the
time you know what you should really
do that's that's yeah which he finds
very
amusing so he's got over 100 cattle and
he's got these 60 heers every year that
get impregnated by one bull right so
there one bulll that does all the work
and he keeps a bull for in this case he
had a bow for four years and this bulll
when I saw it I was like oh man where he
walks like the ground like shakes the
females part they like bow their head
it's like The Lion King right like his
balls are the size of coconuts like like
what men in Austin the patriarchy they
aspire to here like that religion that I
see men here go for is that bll they
need to spend time with that ball and
everything will be fine they need Bronze
Statues B yeah and so when I you know
was with he was like the problem is this
bull has been here for four years
meaning is now impregnated not just the
heers but their daughters their sisters
their granddaughters like the the cows
don't care they just you know so at some
point you need to get a new bowl yeah so
he goes and gets this new bowl that he's
very excited about
and he comes and brings the bowl and the
first thing the bull does when it comes
to the farm is it like nuzzles up to me
and is really nice to me and it's just
this very like sweet bow and over the
next like few weeks every time I see the
bowl he's off like picking flowers or
like hanging out with this little like
orphan male calf and like licking him
and like the females are literally just
staring at him you know cuz they're all
in heat and nothing's happening and I
said your bull might be
gay and he's like and this is where it
gets interesting because this is this is
where it gets interesting yeah is where
he's like that's impossible he's like
you know we tested it it's firm it's
very healthy it's it's like it's a good
Bull and the chance of bull being gay
and not impregnating these 60 females
he's like it's maybe like
05% in my head all I'm thinking about is
worst case scenario because if that bull
is gay that means he not only you know
doesn't get these 60 females pregnant he
loses a season he loses all the money
from the Cs that's coming and it's it's
literally like a catastrophic thing that
can happen to and I realized that that
people entertain worst case scenarios
differently his is
statistically this isn't happening so
therefore I'm not going to prepare for
it I'm not going to spend a dollar
preparing for that worst case scenario
cuz statistically it doesn't make sense
all I care about in life is the worst
case scenario so to me the moment I'm
like that bull is gay all I'm doing is
finding all the evidence that it's gay
and being like here's the action plan
for the gay bll we are you know getting
every female pregnancy tested you're
having the vet come out you're checking
the sperm again you're doing this you're
bringing out that fancy machine that
like triggers them like it's I'm
spending in my head I'm getting them to
spend thousands of dollars on this gay
Bowl to make sure it still gets them
pregnant like artificial insemination
everything and I realized like it's just
a different way that we operate I told
my assistant this on day one I said your
job is to always think of the worst case
scenario and Ure against it like that's
your only job like every day what's the
worst thing that can happen and make
sure it doesn't happen mhm
and doesn't think that way cuz he says
that that costs money H because it just
does you spend too much money on things
that statistically shouldn't happen and
I thought there's something profound in
that so your bull might be gay has
become the kind of like flag waving MTO
of the farm because turns out the bull
was not g it secretly got them all all
private when we weren't watching that's
the the funny part so he was right and
therefore it validates you know he
thinks it validates him but to me I
think I get calmer and more at peace
when that worst case scenario is
protected
against if this is a shorthand where
your partner when you're catastrophizing
can say s this may be a your bow might
be gay
scenario are you finding that you
can use that experience to recalibrate a
little bit do you need an external
Source like your partner to be like Pat
you on the side like a sort of OV
excited horse and be like everything's
going to be okay everything's be okay
because you and I I mean you and I are
very similar in this way I haven't had
the the gay bull experience or the
thought to be gay bull experience but
you and I have bonded over this worst
case scenario catastrophizing which
clearly if it had no utility we wouldn't
use it but in excess sort of becomes its
opposite right it's a helpful tool and
then it becomes a hindrance at a certain
point but see I cheat CU I offload it to
my assistant like that's his job like I
literally I'm like you're the worst case
scenario person so he's in charge of
uring against those things and now that
you know he's been with me a while like
in a way that's become his thing and
he's even more kind of obsessive about
predicting all those things and it's
what makes him so amazing you know you
know as he's risen in the ranks and so
in a way like I'm a little lucky that
I'm not the one staying awake Outsource
some of you're worry 100% I think having
a partner who has the opposite Viewpoint
if I was with someone who also had the
worst case scenario dangerous yeah
dangerous cuz then you're
just who's going to you know Screw in
the light bulb when you know you're too
busy
worrying against all the other like
things that are never going to happen
you know at some point you know someone
has to take care of like the the basic
so yeah I think I think can ofs is
important the Outsourcing your worry to
your assistant your your EA makes me
think of this chapter which was an
excerpt that I had in my very first book
from AJ Jacobs and I think it was
literally called Outsourcing your life
from originally Esquire I want to say
and at one point he was trying to see
how much he could give his virtual
assistant at that point in India and at
one point he realized AJ is amazing he's
written a lot of great books my
favorite's probably the Year of Living
biblically but he's written a lot of
great books and
he at one point was was really worried
about something and he just decided as
an experiment to see if he could ask his
assistant to worry on his behalf if that
would make him feel better no real
solution no fixing anything he's just
like would you mind worrying about this
on my behalf and I mean he's a humorist
right so he does a lot of funny stuff
but he actually found it therapeutically
valuable just the broad Strokes
instruction could you worry about this
so I know someone's worrying about it
like I realize it's not productive but
could you worry about it this will come
back this will come back up well it's
also funny because I think it's uniquely
suited to the young to be able to have
that mindset and what and I told him I
said if you can Master this thing of
thinking about the worst case scenarios
and everything that's what I did when I
was young and working as assistant
you're going to be like a mega Mogul one
day you just will cuz like that's part
of your thinking in a way that it isn't
for other people so yeah the Andy Grove
only the paranoids survive kind of thing
only the paranoids stay up at night
staring at the ceiling too but there is
that so the question about the assistant
what other instructions have you found
or principles make for training an
excellent assistant and I'm asking
because I'm in the process right now of
actually training some new folks on my
team so this is very top of mind for me
I think to me the most important thing
especially when you find someone who
just has so much talent and
capability like June has is
that I
don't give tasks I give massive projects
that are extraordinarily difficult you
know and what would be an example if you
an example would be like in the case of
DC I was like I don't know anything
about DC Comics what am I writing about
like what am I going to do what am I
writing about yeah what am I doing
because in this case it's a it's a
general world that I'm just I don't know
anything so I said oh you had to work
with their characters their characters
it's not original it's working with
their characters so that's where it all
went oh yeah you got you were I was
headed already you were already in
trouble so in that case I was like it's
not that I'm looking for a storyline I'm
just looking for all right knowing what
I'm interested in give me some
characters from there that are
interesting give me a world that's
interesting show me some things in DC
that and so rather than it being like
make me a list of this or like something
very like task oriented procedural it'll
just be like show me something and
that's kind of like the bigger thing and
then giving freedom for him to structure
it him to figure out how he's going to
present it him to have investment in it
you know so the same thing when we did
be some beauty we were presenting it to
the studios to get a buyer for the TV
series I said how do we present this
right how do we present the book you
know come up with whatever you think is
the best way and ultimately he designed
this amazing presentation and therefore
when we sell it it's easy for me to go
to the studio and say June has to be a
producer on it because he was the one
who L the whole presentation so it's
that sort of thing it's like I give very
once in a while give very few like task
oriented things and more like worry
about this for me you all right I'm
going to ask very maybe boring may be
interesting we'll see but certainly kind
of Monday and practical question yeah do
you do all your own inbox management or
do you have I do all you all your now is
that a manageable inbound volume you've
just figured out policies and maybe how
to hide yourself effectively so you
don't get an inordinate amount of stuff
yeah I think it's if it's scheduling if
it's I'll just I'll pass all that stuff
on to him so he will do yes he's keeping
the TR running on time 100% 100% 100%
but I still manage my own email inbox I
just am sorting stuff over there what
kind of stuff would you say buckets wise
what kind of stuff does does he handle
scheduling scheduling School visits
anything that involves a calendar date M
so and also negotiating that's the I get
asked to speak constantly whether it's
you know adults looking for a spark a
creative spark at a corporation or
whether it's schools or whether it's a
Book Festival it's
just you've been through this many many
speaking you're a far better speaker and
presenter than I am I don't
know you know what if they're teenagers
I feel completely at home adults
sometimes I'm like are your mind's
Frozen like is there anything I can do
to away at the calcification on your
brain sometimes I feel that way so his
job is to figure out somehow
subliminally without you know making a
mess of it is is do they have a budget
like what's it's all and you have rules
or at least guidelines place where
you're like hey this is the the lowest
hurdle Etc okay so your bull might be
gay and uh there's so many good options
well let's hop to the secret card which
was a last minute
Edition and we can chat about any person
you
think people should pay attention to or
that you're simply paying attention to
have you um heard of this guy named
Christopher Marley No he is an artist
but his canvas only works
with preserved animals from strange
parts of the Earth tell me more so he's
almost like Indiana Jones he works with
like remote tribes in the amaz like
he'll just go all over the Earth to find
animals we've never seen before MH and
then makes art out of them Christopher
Marley Christopher Marley and so I have
all of his books and I saw an exhibition
of his in person and it was the most
inspiring beautiful thing I have ever
seen I mean that's a strong statement it
is and that's coming from someone who's
exposed to Art like you're exposed to my
life yeah but this is because they're
real animals and so the idea of I spend
my life creating fantasies and then to
see that the real world has more
Fantastical things than you'll ever
see he has just so many great ones where
you'll see like he'll just make art out
of maybe a thousand butterflies that
he's collected but the of the
butterflies are you've never seen stuff
like this before it's almost like you
know when you think of the deep sea fish
that you've never seen before he's
finding this up on land so the Beetles
the snakes the this and he but then he
has this additional Talent of making the
most spectacular art out of it so that
it almost looks if they were fake M it
would still be equally impressive so
that the fact that he's going there
making these relationships getting
animals that convincing these tribes to
hold on to animals that that they find
for hand like it's the whole thing is
insane and the fact that this guy is the
most famous person in the world to me is
shocking how did you come
across North Carolina taking we on a
family reunion trip and we went to the
museum with my niece and nephew who are
teenagers and that was the little fun
thing then I bought all his books I
follow him in on Instagram and I just
think it's the most amazing thing yeah
as soon as you start looking at his art
you're gonna be like
and also he has a crazy story which is
they had a photo of him up on the wall
and I was like that's him he was a
supermodel he was a supermodel this like
rugged supermodel who then I don't know
used his his wealth to then like do what
he really wanted to do which was like be
Indiana Jones and then incredible but
the the talent is like insane like the
way he places everything I almost want
to like pause for a second and show you
the artart let's do it yeah sure let me
take a look oh you have to see it cuz
once you see it you're going to want to
like make him your best
friend oh wow okay all right that's wild
that's just one if you go back to the
grid you'll just see tons of them oh
yeah okay so this is at Christopher
Marley Studio spelled like Bob Marley
Christopher Marley Studio almost $60,000
followers it should be 6
million all vertebrates are reclaimed
specimens none are killed for art that
was going to be one of my questions all
right this is going to be a thing and
you're right if there were a game of
match match the face to what you to this
other profession on the other side in
column B I mean this is not to detract
from his work but I'll be like yeah no
no maybe he's doing jeans commercials
maybe he's doing car
commercials but this this artwork is
incredible okay we will we will
definitely link to that check it out
folks Christopher Marley
studio all right check check my next
follow on Instagram now I'm going to go
to one here that I can't read which is
now pulling my I see I thought it was
kch and then I was like oh wait a second
that's an a is oh that's an a coach
Alpha coach Al what or who is coach
Alpha okay I realized that I can only do
two jobs in my life there's only two
things I'm good at and there's only one
thing I would like to do as much as I
like writing mm and that
is I feel like and it's a job that
should exist and it
doesn't generation Alpha which is
teenagers of today oh I didn't know that
was the thing yeah so after gone back to
a yes so after gen Z is gener and that's
like who are teenagers now they're
growing up in an impossible situation
like with everything that's happening
with the world and the phones getting
more addict it's just impossible like
it's and when I was a tutor I was a
tutor for 10 years I could tutor every
subject that was one of my you know I
was such a nerd in school that I just
really could to on any subject and I
loved it when a parent just sort of
outsourced their entire kind of child's
like home life to me right so but I
loved it because I could get to the
bottom of
what made them tick and what was
important and and starting to really
kind of like not just help them with
school but get them on a better track
like out of their phone and stop
worrying about what everybody else
wanted them to be including their
parents and more focusing on who they
actually were the Mental Health crisis
that's affecting almost all teenagers is
this sort of existential dread and so I
would have loved to if I hadn't become a
writer and I still feel like this is
going to be part of my life somehow is I
would love to be kind of be the like
merry Poppins who can go into a house
and just be like let's let's get this on
track like I'll give you an example in a
way that parents can't so the one kid
was getting off track cuz he was
drinking a lot and you know getting in
trouble and all that sort of stuff and I
noticed that every time I saw him he was
talking about you know going out parying
and at the end of the night having
wrestling matches with all his friends
and just like getting into these sort of
physical fights with people and he was
always beating up on his younger
brothers like every time I saw him he
was like they were just always physical
with this thing and one day like trying
to solve all the other stuff the
academic stuff yeah just you know
everything else and I thought to myself
I just said to him I said you know and
his whole goal in life was to be popular
and party and all that stuff and I said
I don't know if partying is your your
goal in reality I feel like your real
goal is that you want to fight like
that's what you actually want to do like
what you really want to do is is not
drink and like hang hang out with your
friends it's you want to drink so you
can beat them up at the end of the night
and get into these like you know like
Agro every every night ended in
aggro and I researched I said there's a
UFC Gym like four minutes from your
house go take a
class 16-year-old go take a class mhm
takes a class loves it is now there like
three four times a week having the time
of his life drinking went way down
everything got back on track got a job
to fund the UFC like thing like
everything's fine wow no we're beating
up the brothers why I didn't need to
he's getting he can beat up anyone just
need an outlet just need an outlet but
what parents could to say go fight you
know yeah after school they just they're
not going to do it it's stuff like that
where I just feel like
sometimes kids need to be seen for who
they are and in order for us to get out
of this crisis I think people are like
oh Mental Health crisis all these things
that I feel like there needs to be a
third
party you know whether it's even as much
as like teen groups like I was just
thinking about the fact that like on any
given night if you're an alcoholic or
you have a drug addiction or whatever
you can just go to an AA meeting and you
can have that group experience and I
felt like why isn't there that for
teenagers like this idea that you can
just go to a space and meet other
teenagers on a given night and have that
kind of place to talk to or experience
and yes you can do it online but I just
think the more you get into your phone
the further you often get away from
actually who you are and connect and
real connection
so I don't know I have no formal
thoughts on how this should happen I
just I do miss that part of my old job
which was going into the house and
helping kids footnote for people who may
have missed our earlier conversations
well into your writing career correct if
I'm wrong fact check please you held on
to your
tutoring because it gave you a safety
net but also I guess the
psychological reassurance of knowing
that you didn't have to White Knuckle
desperately make the first bug that came
your way through the writing I mean is
that a fair description we don't have to
spend too much time on it but it's
important as an example to me because a
lot of creatives who do really well do
not burn the ships behind them they do
not block all the exits they actually
have some type
of backup in the form that you did 100%
and because also it meant that I could
take all the risks in my writing right
so even
now I know I can do other jobs I could
go back to tutoring I could teach at a
university I could work with kids and
teenagers in some way so I'm happy to
take the risk on this book instead of
chasing the money
because there's no pressure on it you
know what I mean so I think that's the
important thing I feel like if you're
writing with that desperate White
Knuckle mercenary form money it
increases the chance that what you're
writing is you're trying to to fit them
mhm you know so coach Alpha is this a
public attempt to give away an idea if
let's just say you you can't get a taker
let's just say you don't see it would
you ever think of doing I know this
isn't in person right but would you ever
think of
doing a series of talks and then pulling
from that and putting together a course
making lectures available for free maybe
they're targeted at parents maybe
they're targeted at kids I mean if if
this for whatever reason doesn't get
takers right Alpha because it also
requires it's not just an idea that can
be executed by anyone but to underscore
something you said the third party piece
is really important right like I can
get not anyone but almost anyone to
change behaviors yeah sometimes except
for the people closest to me right
because to them I'm just Tim you know
what I mean and sometimes you can
develop a selective deafness around the
people you're closest to so then when
you have a third party who's credible
there's a lot of Leverage there well
even I was thinking about teenagers
right let's say you have and this I told
parents this many times most of the time
they didn't listen but it was I gave
them the secret which was when your kid
takes initiative and does something on
their own like they start making their
bed or they start working out you know
after school do not mention it don't say
it's great you made the bed or that's so
cool that you're working out do not and
it's your thing that means every time
they're going to go make the bed they're
now thinking of your approval and little
by little it's going to stop them doing
it huh because it's now become your
thing leave it it's their thing how many
kids have you tutored over the years
would you say oh God at least a few
hundred few hundred yeah probably a few
hundred I miss it but also I got the the
connection through the books and also
what's funny is I started doing writing
camps where I got hosted by writing camp
camps and there was always a curriculum
that they wanted us to teach or whatever
and I would just go in there and do my
own thing and the first thing I would
work on with each kid is when you write
you need to know what your characters
want and you need to know at the deepest
basis level let's say a character wants
to play lacrosse right like that's He
Wants To Be A Champion lacrosse player
that's where most people will stop but
you need to ask well why does he want to
be a champion lacrosse player in order
to please his why does he want to drink
that's not
it's because he wants to fight at the
end of the night fight and why does he
want to fight at the end of the day you
have to keep going down until you hit a
base level like is he trying to save his
self-esteem is he trying to prove
something to his family like you know
whatever it is and then on the second
day after we work on that with
characters I do that for themselves so
the teenager I'm like what what do you
want in front of the class so there's
usually 12 people and that's when you
start to get somewhere I feel like I
could use that exercise now but that's
how for college essays so my specialty
when I was tutoring was college essays I
used to go in there and help them come
up with the perfect essay topic all I
needed was 3 days with them and I would
spend 3 days asking that question over
and over and looking at pieces of their
life and us talking about it until we
came up with what do you want and why do
you want it and then making the essay
from there all right I'll bite so what's
the next step once you go through that
exercise how do you craft the
narrative the essay how do you put it
into essay form
is it describing really what you want I
mean is that the topic of the essay or
do you use that as Grist for the- Mill
it becomes the heart of it and then from
there you can start to to build
everything out did you start doing this
before you were working on fiction or
did it happen simultaneously saney
because as I was working on school for
Gen evil the thing I had you had to
think about it and also because I'd come
from film school where they drill into
you what does your character want why do
they want it and I did that every page
of that book which is why I think it
reads quickly because you just know what
everybody wants at any given moment and
I realize that I'm working with these
kids and no one knows what they want
they follow the flow in the wrong
direction because the flow is taking
them towards anxiety and comparison and
all the things that the world you know
if I spend my life on Instagram and Tik
Tok I would die cuz it's just the wrong
inputs to make me find what I want to do
you know
yeah coach Alpha coach Alpha I love it
all right
this is needed this is this is needed I
mean I was very fortunate when I was 15
16 to have a few
mentors male mentors figures who by hook
or crook were able to help me correct
course in a number of ways if I had not
had that input I think things could have
ended and I do mean ended in very sort
of Terminal Way very differently should
talk about another person on my list
then let's do it he just moved to Austin
his name is Mike
regula
rega he is an ex Navy SEAL M and he is
here
starting a company called course of
action which what I want to do for
teenagers he's doing for men
mhm and it's using basic Navy SEAL kind
of Concepts and training to basically
get men to both individually and in
groups look at their lives and make
proactive change to become more
connected to what they want so basically
you know it's every man who feels like
they haven't quite found their way back
onto a path or they've lost their tribe
or anything like that he's just trying
to find us a kind of safe space for men
to work on whether it's psychological
part the nutrition part the fitness part
the emotional part and in
groups and I think it it's just so
needed especially in this world so I
just think he's someone to look out for
and I think the the website is one COA
one COA for course of action we'll find
it and we'll link to it as well how did
you find Mike or course of action oh he
was introduced to me through this is the
best
story The Boy I was in love with in high
school was this kid named Noah who I was
obsessed with of course you know he's
now married with Children everything
like that everyone knew this story
except him and then one day someone told
him you do realize that someon spent
like most of his high school career
trying to get your attention and he just
was like what and so then we reconnected
became friends and he's like you have to
meet Mike because you know I don't know
what it was Mike was in New York and he
just felt like we would Bond and we met
and that was that was that that was that
he's just a special person and I just
feel like we were talking about this
like the same way I feel about
resuscitating the teenage m mind and
soul he feels about men you know because
I think he's seen it all having been an
exal for sure check it out he's right
here right here in my hometown Mike
regula and this is actually not the
first time I've heard his name this
rings a bell and I can't place he
friends with all your friends oh there
we
go there you go that's probably why I've
heard His
Name all right does does anything catch
your eye that might make for good next
Scooby Snack conversationally
speaking we could go to you know what
here how about this oh that's a good one
all right intermittent pop star this is
in the Absurd category this in the
Absurd category cuz I should not still
be doing this but in
2017 I went to this book festival for
the first time in Charleston called the
all Fest um that is like the biggest
Book Festival for teenagers in the
country yeah about 20,000 kids descend
on this thing everybody comes there it's
where new projects are it's just a big
Festival that takes over Charleston to
get invited is means you've like
officially made it and all I ever wanted
in my career was to get invited because
it's not your publisher can't pitch you
it's like one of these Sun Valley yeah
you must be invited must be invited so I
finally get invited I'm so excited and I
go and it's the best two days of my life
I'm having the most amazing time and I
go to the final show called the
smackdown which they charge like $12 to
get into it's 3,000 people in Charleston
Music Hall it's the most beautiful
theater and the authors participate in
this kind of variety show and I sit
there and watch the worst show I've ever
seen about it is an Abomination to make
3,000 people sit through that I was the
fact that I had to participate in some
little part of it and I remember having
this thing secretly thinking I'm going
to take over this show and turn it into
my own private like
pop concert and it's going to be amazing
and it's going to be awesome and it's
going to be like The Greatest Show on
Earth I just remember having this
thought like it was just like this is my
fantasy and it's going to happen you
know I grew up idolizing you know this
everyone who knows me knows this but I
should probably say it I grew up a huge
Madonna fan like that was my pop st
growing up I'm obsessed with Taylor
Swift I'm obsessed with anyone who can
translate whatever their talent is
into some kind of cool Showmanship cut
to two years later they were like no one
wants to host this show do you want to
host it and I was like dud I'd earned
enough credit to be like okay I said
sure as long as I can completely redo it
100% my way how did they think to come
to you had you planted the seed somehow
were you like not a bad show I could do
better on the way out I didn't say I I
tear in the eye I think I said this
could be
better so we love your feedback yeah
have a few words this could be better
got it so they came to you came to me
and then I was like we're going to do
the variety show it's going to be all
new games and it's going to start with
an eight song six costume change dance
number dedicated to whatever the themes
are in ya almost like a version of like
Billy Crystal's old Oscar thing but even
more
extreme I don't know what made me do it
but what was interesting is while we
started working on it and we got a
choreographer and I I don't know how to
dance and I started learning these dance
steps it was that process of training
for it learning how to dance learning
how to do choreography that was so
awesome cuz it got me out of my head and
I started to fall in love with this
process of Designing a show Designing
things designing themes it was a new way
of telling a story from beginning to end
how do you entertain an audience of
3,000 people for 10 minutes like I fell
in love with it and had the best time
but then I did it I think I did it the
next year I've done it three times and
what I've realized is if I do it every
two years cuz it's so much work it's so
much money it's of my own it's so much
work so much time right in the red
column just throwing money on fire but
if I do it every two years that means
the year in between someone else some
poor soul has to come and try and it's
inevitably a disaster so then when I
come back I get to the hero
returns every two
years it's like you know Julia Roberts
strategy was was brilliant when she was
an actress the reason she had such
longevity is she always did one movie
where she had her hair red and curly and
did a romcom and then she would do one
when she hacked it off and played like
Frankenstein's like made you know some
crazy Indie weird thing but because she
did it every other movie whenever she
came back it was like oh thank God she's
back and doing pretty woman so what's
been important for me is it's less
about I get more than enough attention
for the books and everything I don't
need that sort of
it's not a a sure it is a narcissistic
thing what am I what am I saying what
this is such a lie what a lie terrible
um but I think what I enjoy more than
the actual performance is the runup it's
the day before rehearsals start I'm
always nauseous I don't want to do it I
don't want to to go through that whole
experience and then because it's
everything I'm bad at MH there's a
Japanese word have you heard misogi
there's a book about this that um have
to look it up to find happiness I think
Mike was telling me about this Japanese
concept that once a year or once every
two years you have to do something
completely out of your comfort zone that
is an extended journey and in doing that
you find like new reinvigoration for
life and I think that's mine like every
two years to go into this thing where I
don't know how it's going to end I don't
know if it's going to work because
always it's more ambitious or more
interesting so it's funny because this
one was bigger and crazier I just did it
a couple months ago than anything we
hadd ever done before and at the party I
was like there's no way there's just I
know myself I can't top that SK what we
did and someone goes well what are you
going to do now are you going to are you
going to sing and I was like haha and
then I thought huh
[Laughter]
well you know you don't know I mean I
doubt that's what it's going to be but
it's always like when you think you
can't find what the next thing is it's
like what's the next zone of discomfort
so that's the silly thing I still do but
I think it's important for me somehow I
can't really let go of it you know at
this yeah definitely definitely yeah how
would your life be different if it were
taken away like if it were just
subtracted how would your experience the
rest of the year be different if there's
an answer to that yeah it wouldn't be as
fun there's something so energizing
about the high stakes nature of a show
and also my assistant is this amazing
dancer and musician so he's part of it
he's the back I have backup dancers and
he's one of them so it's like we're this
like ride together where it can end in
super embarrassment because you've got
thousands of people with their phones
out like yeah there's no you had to be
there there's let me show you would
happened it feels very high stakes in in
the moment so you know where writing is
never in the moment really cuz you were
constantly revising this is immediate
and I just think it's awesome it's also
out of your head like you mentioned yes
I always feel in incredible shape
mentally and physically after 6 weeks of
this stuff yeah I'm going to force a
segue we'll see if it's a natural segue
but drugs yeah this is in the yellow I
believe changed your mind about yeah
category I never did drugs growing up I
may maybe did pot once or twice and
found it slowed me down to the point of
I never wanted to do it again and just
sort of Walled that whole thing off as I
don't know stuff that other people do
mhm and then during Co I read the body
keeps of score mhm and you know I had
struggled with some things from my
entire life in terms of anxiety and and
just getting stuck in kind of ruts of
feeling and it was 2021 January where I
just remember talking about follow the
flow I stood up went to my computer I
remember being in Miami in my parents
house
Googling ketamine treatment New York
City I knew nothing about ketamine like
nothing how was it even in your field
just popped into the head I don't know I
just remember going KY there in New York
City calling up scheduling the
consultation and a week later I'm back
in New York going to to meet the doctor
and I I was like I don't know if I'm
right for this I don't want anything
that will mess with my creativity I said
the only reason I'm entertaining this
idea is because it's in a doctor's
office I said I would never do drugs on
my own because the fear surrounding that
of what could happen and what the where
it's procured from and all that stuff
would end up infecting the whole
experience M and with a doctor's office
you know I'm entertaining it I said but
I don't want it to affect my creativity
I don't want it to he's like it's only
to make you more yourself and more
creative but he goes these are the three
things that I think make for a good
candidate he's like number
one have you felt emotionally numb for
most of your life and at that point in
my life absolutely I think I was in a
just cycles of numbness number two was
did you have a volatile childhood where
emotions were not particularly welcome
and I was like
check
check check in number three he goes this
one's the most important he's like do
you know how to have
fun and I said no and I cried I remember
crying in the office he's like do you
know how to have fun and I was the first
time anyone had asked the the question
in the right way cuz I knew the idea of
fun I knew that I should be having fun I
knew how to act like I was having fun
but I never felt like I was having fun
and he's like like and he goes you don't
drink I said no and he goes and I
meditate I was that point four or five
years into meditation he's like you're
going to have a very good response to
this he just like instantly and so I
started ketamine
treatments at that time I think you do
six and 12 days and then you go back for
a booster in my case it's every 10 weeks
and I still go and it changed my life I
mean it was like I feel like a totally
different person because of those cuz
what it did is it woke up parts of my
brain that I didn't know existed because
they had shut off so early that I didn't
know they were there and then all of a
sudden I started to get glimpses of what
I could be like you know and then it
became a question of could I hold on to
that and little by little over some
people I think get their benefits much
quicker or they don't get any benefits
at all I mean it's so individual in my
case it was almost like a practice it
was like every 10 weeks I'd go learn a
million
things work on those things in between M
go back and it almost became
like my version of like the deepest
therapy you know and I think it's become
it's become a
huge just reason for everything and I
think it's also allowed me to follow the
flow more than ever because the whole
thing of of a ketamine treatment is it's
a sedative right so it puts your brain
in such a relaxed state that you have no
choice but to follow the flow where it
goes and the flow usually leads you
closer to the truth
so I don't know I think it's for someone
who was so
anti-drugs it was the biggest thing that
changed my mind about yeah just to
establish some Basics with the whatever
it was let's call it six sessions in 12
days so that loading phase let's call it
or like induction phase those were IV or
IV I've never done the micro doing and
the nasal spray and all that sort of
stuff because again I want to do
anything that is me
alone always a great policy I just want
to emphasize how good a decision that is
a lot of friends I know who have
embraced more recreational use have
become addicted to ketamine oh I'm sure
it has that potential and you're also in
a
sense a great candidate SL profile
because you don't have any history of
alcohol use yeah some people who have a
history of alcohol abuse or just use
like extens use which certainly if you
go to New York City and I've spent a lot
of time in New York City a lot of social
life revolves around alcohol and many
people there have switched to ketamine
but it's still a dissociative anesthetic
so in those uncontrolled
environments people can find themselves
in a slide that can become U very
precarious but in the clinical setting I
also find ketamine to be incredibly
interesting there's a lot of search
people can find on PubMed and elsewhere
looking at the rapid anti-depressant
effects of Academy and their different
types for people who might be interested
in the potential benefits and risks and
science related to this I did an episode
with Dr John Crystal of Yale who did he
was the primary investigator on a lot of
the seminal work investigating ketamine
as anti-depressant in humans and
developed some of the early protocols
with his his his fellow researchers and
scientists which is tricky because any
time anybody I talk to people close to
me they're like do you recommend it I'm
like no and I never recommend it to
people I don't think I've ever
recommended it to anyone because I found
it difficult it's a journey into the
deepest core of yourself it's a lot yeah
it's a lot of work and the meditation
background also serves you I would
imagine in a very big way in terms of
navigating some of these recesses yeah
what do your boosters look like is that
a single
session and in those single sessions
what does the format look like music no
music visual no nothing and it's alone
there's no therapist after it's just I
don't I I do it in
silence and I just follow the flow
wherever it takes me and it usually
takes me on a ride to the uncomfortable
things that I'm not dealing with then
you know it's almost like the way I
describe it is sometimes I feel like
what the kenam is doing is relaxing your
your brain like pathway by pathway and
whenever it gets somewhere sticky that's
like shut off where there's a jam that's
where you're going to have a little
moment you know that's when the traffic
helicopters Circle the traffic CH and
then you have to you know but I just
think it's over time because I've been
willing to sort of do the work and sort
of be in there with
it it's been a huge thing and it meant
that I never had to take
anti-depressants I never had to take
anti- anxiety medication things that
someone on my profile probably would
have needed mhm but instead you know to
go three four times a year and do these
sessions I think and it's also the great
thing about it is it's a short halflife
it's over so fast so I think that's what
makes
it has been such a huge contributor for
me how long would you say your active
session lasts 1 hour one hour exactly 1
hour and then just the process of like
getting out of your system you coming
back up all that stuff is probably
another hour and a half M so by the time
you're in your Uber home then you're
you're good to go some interesting
applications to treatment resistant
depression and chronic pain also yeah I
did six infusions several years ago and
I came in without any particular acute
state of anxiety or depression yeah
so the people working there the staff
and technicians and
MDS and so on were're a little
mystified and I therefore didn't have
much in terms of measurable reductions
because I wasn't coming in with
something to reduce at that point yes
but I left and a few weeks later I
realized oh my God that midback thoracic
pain that I have felt every day for
several years I have not felt in
probably a month it's amazing because
anything that's coming from a place of
stress
you know but the thing is it could
return yeah if you don't deal with that
psychological stress it might return but
yeah yeah yeah for sure I felt that too
like if I go in with a lot of muscle
soreness I'll come back out and it's
almost like it never happen so for
people want to learn more certainly John
Crystal with a K Crystal and Ander
hubman also recently had an episode
related to All Things Kine which I'm
sure involved a lot of due diligence so
you can check that out the double this
is in the excited about category what is
the double super excited about I've been
thinking about this one a lot which
is there's so much work on your Shadow
Self in Psychology right it's always
like oh get control of your Shadow Self
Your Shadow Self is you know and the
more I I think about it and The more
I've gone through my Journeys and and
all my kind of Evolutions I'm realizing
that most of the time you're the Shadow
Self you the actor you're the problem
the better version of yourself is
actually out there you're double right
and so I think you have to flip it at
any given moment and it's a good
exercise to do all day long like just a
mental thought
experiment what if I'm the shadow and
there's a better version of myself like
completely independent human like
outside that door that could take over
this life and completely handle it with
no issues right and so it's been
something that's if you look at all my
fiction all my fiction is about some
version of twins like one good one evil
one this one that one and it's always I
think it's that it's that I'm always
trying to figure out like Am I who I'm
supposed to be and I think often
psychology will say well you have to get
control of that shadow and sometimes I'm
like well no maybe I just need to not be
here and let the double be in charge you
know and so I think it's something I'll
be exploring in everything I do because
I think is such an important concept
that we we've reversed it and that we
shouldn't be afraid of the Shadow cuz
the Shadow's actually uh staring right
back at
us when does this thought this concept
come up for
you and I'll buy you just a second at a
time so I have I have a friend who's
calm in almost all circumstances
certainly compared to me Matt Mullen wig
and there have been times
when I have thought to myself you know
what would Matt Mullen wig do almost
like a reminder bracelet some people for
JC and so on and that has been very
helpful when I'm in a situation I feel
myself on the verge of becoming
disregulated not like Hulk smash but
just having some type of rumination or
tantrum internally that is not helpful
I'm like pause what would Matt M do and
I'm like you know what how he would
handle this is he would do d d du and
then sometimes I just do that thing and
I'm like well that wasn't so hard so I'm
curious if there times
when you feel your lesser self doing
something or I guess in this case your
Shadow right doing something where
you're like what would my double do how
does it come up it came up first because
I was going to be on the Kelly Clarkson
show two years ago and i' had never been
on kind of like a TV show like that and
you know was live suud in the audience
it was straight out of covid and I was
like I'm just I'm not ready for like I
just don't know how to do this you know
like did you decide to do that or that
been that came suggested to you yeah
yeah so the publicist was like we booked
you on Kelly and I was like I don't know
especially after lockdown and I just
like not ready for it was the f I think
one of the first shows that she had
people back and I
remember in the dressing room starting
to freak out and panic and I could feel
that Panic Rising then all of a sudden I
felt this like counterforce where I was
like stressing on my phone I felt myself
like put the phone down and I just felt
some other presence be like
it's fine we got this and I almost
remember in that moment being like okay
I just felt it you know like and that
was the first time I'd ever felt
something like that cuz I went I
remember sitting on the couch and
feeling totally chill like David Duvy
was next to me I had grown up watching X
Files I made a sex joke with him in the
first like two seconds of the thing like
I just like totally chill and I just was
like what I'm literally watching myself
being like what is happening and that
was the first time I got a sense of like
oh wait the possibility there's a better
version that can handle every situation
you know and I remember the other thing
that gave me a clue was Tiger Woods
there was a documentary about Tiger
Woods on HBO and they talked about how
his dad taught him kind of techniques to
almost hypnotize himself when he played
so that his conscious mind wasn't
working and that's how we dominated all
those years and I thought that's it it's
almost like you have to get your
conscious brain out of the way because
the double the real version of yourself
that knows how to do everything is there
somewhere you know and the question is
over time can you make it so they start
to integrate and a useful thing that
also helped me start to explore it was I
started
doing ifs do you know this internal
family systems yeah I've had the founder
dick Schwarz on the podcast way so I
started doing ifs
therapy exploring those parts and that's
when you really start to be able to see
them in practice and work with them and
start to feel more comfortable letting
go and so I think ifs was I think the
ketamine treatments plus ifs plus Kelly
Clarkson plus that Kelly Clarkson moment
was sort of the secret I think about a
few years ago where everything sort of
came together personally do you have
thoughts for how you're going to explore
that or implement it I think it comes
really it's in therapy and it's in those
kmy treatments where I think sometimes
what I'll do now is if I go in for a
booster or if I go in for ifs I just
think okay I'm taking myself out of this
let's see what comes from the other part
of myself you know what I mean like the
part that is the creative force is the
one that has the vision of where I
should be going next the one who knows
what next book I should be writing oh
light unbidden yeah like I would like to
have a better connection to the thing
that is running my life MH you know
which why we should talk about QBs next
QBs QBs is this quarterbacks it is and
this is so funny the most spiritual
Revelations I've ever had watching a TV
show have come watching that Netflix
series quarterback oh I haven't I
haven't seen it I've only heard of it it
is amazing it follows Patrick Mahomes
Kirk Cousins and Marcus Mariota for the
2022 season All Pause how did
you I feel like I know you pretty well
how did you end up watching quarterbacks
Taylor started dating Travis so then I
felt like okay t- Swift is another card
yeah we'll get that so I felt like okay
I grew up watching a lot of dolphins
games and I actually love football like
I could watch football all day long I
just never really got into it because I
didn't have a a reason you know I me
there was no team I was rooting for and
the Dolphins always sucked for a long
time so Taylor gave me more reason and
so I just watched it because I'd also
been hearing good things and I love
sports talks like I just feel like it's
the closest thing I can feel to like
high performance you've played a lot of
tennis also for people who don't have
the background mhm so I start watching
it and I realized that this position of
being a quarterback is the greatest
metaphor for what life should be because
we all think we're the decision makers
this is what we're talking about follow
the flow we think we're the ones in
charge of everything like that that's
not what a quarterback is Right
quarterback knows all the possible plays
right the other forces are calling it
into his helmet he's not even like able
to talk to the coach he can't talk back
to the coach it's a one-way system so
literally it's Universe telling him what
the play is right so he's hearing like
white squall Madonna 6 Wing whatever
right he's like okay execute right so
that's it and I feel like that's what
life should be you're in the flow so
much that the orders are coming from
outside right orders are coming from
outside telling you what the play is you
get the play you go into the Huddle you
communicate the play to your whole team
now everybody's on the same page as you
like you've got everyone with you right
now you go into the Huddle the ball is
snapped to you and now you have to
adjust because the world's going to
react to your play right and that's
where it gets interesting because you
have to be so present and in the moment
that you can react to what's going to
happen and to me like that's life
everyone's focused so much on deciding
to play Don't focus on deciding to play
once you feel a play execute it right
like just go like follow it and if it
busts what whatever you got a new play
coming and so each of them had such a
great Strate each of them is so
different Mahomes is just sort of a
physical freak of nature and so smart
and able to on the Fly improvise and so
he's very kind of I think of him as
almost pliable he's very spongy he can
sort of like move and adjust at the last
minute and he's so sort of you know
confident in that ability K cousins is
more like me where he's not particularly
physically Adept but he's brainy and
nerdy and so he where the other
quarterbacks are in the gym like doing
all their physical training he's at biof
feedback sessions cuz he feels like if
he can get his brain to just be calm
like the calmest in the most stressful
situations it'll tell him what to do you
know it's a Roger Federer was similar he
said that every tennis player tenses up
right as they're about to hit the ball
cuz the pressure of hitting the right
shot gets them at the last NC and his
job is to stay relaxed so has an extra
you know millisecond of options and so I
was just something about that show where
I was like these guys are learning to
not be the they don't call the play but
they're the executing guys and I just
think like that's life like let the
plays come to you let let them come
through your invisible headset don't
question it you can't you can't talk
back to it just take the play and then
execute you know so there was something
about that show I don't know I got to
check it out yeah check it out it did it
did something to me at a deep level all
right we're going to jump straight to T
Swift because knowing very little about
Taylor Swift
but watching what was it called
Americana I want to say the documentary
I have a Fascination in the phenomenon
of Taylor Swift and you know the
re-recording of the Masters like some of
these these
fascinating decisions with Incredible
outcomes like I'm very interested but I
know very little but I do recall when
the whole
football Cameo came into Taylor's life
somebody who is more attuned to all of
these pop phenomena said millions of
people swifties are about to become very
interested in
football and that's going to be that's
going to be a curious development like
where does that lead okay so T Swift
it's funny because I grew up idolizing
Madonna and I think one of the reasons I
was so interested Madonna was some part
of me was kind of pre-adapt her Central
exist question of existence to what was
going to be my life which is need
you you're like how is this sentence
going to
end which is as an artist how do you
sustain a career for a long period of
time without it just being a downward
diminishing returns you know and what I
loved about Madonna was that reinvention
the ability to completely reinvent
herself brilliant at doing it and she
did it for so long you know and then now
she's in our close to 70 and her in her
like Legacy celebration era you know
she's done in terms of that part it's
funny because Taylor in a lot of ways
follows the same script which is each
album is a reinvention it's and to the
point of now when she she's on tour it's
the arrow tour it's this idea that like
you're going to embrace all the
different parts of me but they're all
very different and they go in different
directions and and that's part of my
identity now so do not expect me to stay
in the Box for the next thing cuz that's
not what is happening and that's not
what you want so I think it's why when I
went to write fairy tales I think the
fact that I am such a you know also the
the reason it's in the Absurd column is
because I've liked her for so long and
now I'm so used to comparing myself to
her when she wasn't even comparing not
myself but like like her moves and
things that now that she's so popular
it's almost more ridiculous when I tell
people
like well we did both move to Missouri
for 6'5 aggressively masculine athletic
[Applause]
[Laughter]
men so I do feel like a special kinship
but it's this idea of like like okay how
do I not maybe you're light maybe you're
double as tailor I I wonder about that I
had one of the K treat I got you babe
for the Kelly Clarkson she's like we've
done this a million times oh would that
would be awesome can she deposit some of
the
funds of hoarding um but it is this idea
of like how do you make it so not
staying in the box is your thing cuz
that was Madonna thing and that's what I
want mine to be is and that's why
aggressively I can't be afraid of this
next thing when I'm going out with
something so different I'm so excited
for you this was not comparing myself to
Taylor Swift nor to you different
circumstances different time in life but
after the 4-Hour Work
week every pressure including a lot of
internal pressure but every expectation
and pressure was that I was going to do
something in the same category something
with the same brand which I did
obliquely but the 4our work week four
fill in the blank right kind of
franchise the whole thing find splice it
milk it for all it's worth do the three
work whatever it might be but at that
point and you certainly have this
optionality I paused because the
inclination was to rush and whenever
that
is the pressure I tend to hit the brakes
yeah and I'm like wait a
second this has bought me permission to
write another
book this is the time when people are
going to be willing to take a gamble
because this first one went so
bananas I can always go back to the
4-Hour Work Week M yeah that door does
not close yeah or it doesn't get locked
at least Y similarly if you try this new
thing you will be welcome back with open
arms it's Julia Roberts with her long
red hair and I'm here to write more
fairy tales for exactly and that's
that's when I went to the for our body
totally different category a lot of
people assumed within publishing totally
different readership yeah but I was like
if this works yeah if this works it's
not guaranteed to work but if it works
then I buy myself
permission to do things that are not
within this category 100% right and I
can always go back I have the
optionality of hitting control Z in a
sense you know hitting undo and going
back to what I was doing but I also
think that what was interesting about
the
4our body is it
just seems so it's so funny cuz that
anyone would question that it just seems
so obvious cuz you had presented a hack
of the work life so then for you to be
like I'm now presenting a hack of your
physical
existence of course nothing about it
seemed did you feel like this is obvious
I did you did that's the important thing
I did including some of my close friends
like Matt Mullen who I mentioned he was
like yeah of course of because he knew
that for all the notes and Analysis and
so on that I'd put together interviews I
conducted for business I had he knew
there's no reason why my public know
this although I did tell them and to
their credit you know they they they bit
right they were willing to go with for
our body which then took off and
became became very successful but he
knew that I had basically all of my
workouts recorded since age 16 like he
knew the extent to
which I had captured data and
experimented on myself and to him he's
very productive yeah and in Silicon
Valley he's like yeah like the
productivity stuff that's great he's
like but for his peer group he's like
they're all incredibly good at that
right they're all incredibly good at
maximizing per hour output he said what
we're not good at and what we want from
you is actually the more of the physical
stuff right so all of them personally
were asking me questions about the
exercise side and I was like okay the
same lens the same framework the same
principles they can be applied here
that's so interesting because that's so
obvious right what are people asking you
what do people ask me how do I fix my
teenager okay so that's what I'm going
to write about what's just staring you
in the face what's staring you in the
face yeah what is just staring you in
the face all right should we go to
another
person sure I'm really interested in
these two authors who I just feel like
we're in the age of hyper productivity
the rush of content right so you have to
put out a book every year you have to
put out content on Instagram all the
time like this ubiquity of
and I find that the people that
especially the authors that we most hold
on to and the ones that were we start to
get obsessed over and in a weird ironic
way are the most popular on Tik Tok are
the ones who release a book like every
eight years yeah something of Donna
tart as one author and the other one
that sort of goes together with her her
name is Hana and the last name is Jana
Gara and donat tar wrote Goldfinch
secret history she's only written three
books she writes one every 10 years and
she's due for exactly 10 years so she
did one at 29 39 49 and her 59th
birthday just pass so we should be
seeing one any moment and then Han wrote
a little life a little life yes which I
read Yana giara yeah yeah she's the
editor of the te magazine for New York
Times and she wrote this book that is
the most immersive like committed that's
what her and Donna do like they spend
years and years writing their books that
and they become these immersive complete
experiences to the point of they they
just consume you because they're so real
and what I find so interesting is Donna
tart there's a whole section of Tik Tok
dedicated to her little life 10 years
later H it's selling it's like number 20
on Amazon like Tik tok's obsessed with
it and it's because of the level of
commitment of the work that just like
and that's I think what I aspire to deep
down is to be able to just be so
committed to something that you're able
to to have the time and freedom to
spend like a very long time on it so
that you can really create this
alternate thing you know that is
undeniable like it will exist forever
because it's that committed and so those
two authors I think are a sign that no
matter how adult or stupid or short-term
thinking or you know monkey meme we
get it doesn't matter that stuff still
holds because they're the two most
popular authors on Tik Tok why do you
think they are and I know that you just
explained part of picture in your mind
why they are so popular on Tik Tok
because there are many dedicated authors
let's just take as a category of
profession who release books
infrequently yeah who are supremely good
at the craft yeah who are not popular on
Tik Tok mhm
so what do you think it is about these
two even if you had to just make stuff
up speculating what do you think it is
about these two in particular what else
adds to that it goes with this one so
this is together levels of feeling which
is together with Sally Rooney who's
another author who I'm obsessed with
these three authors are able to access a
certain kind of Primal nerve of feeling
because they're so immersed in it like
they're just there that it's the
intensity of reading it just feels
higher than anything else like yes you
can have someone who spent 10 years
crafting this like meticulous world and
all that sort of stuff i' I've read
plenty of books like that but there's
something about the 10 years that is
spent doing that work we talked about
what is a character want why do they
want it why do they want that why do
they want that and they do it for every
character so that when you're reading it
you're just in this like
emotional soup that is undeniable it's
just so affecting to everybody who reads
it there's this category of books
book that I can recommend to anybody who
comes to me and says what book should I
read I always tell them secret history
by Donna tart Little Life by Hana
conversations with Friends by Sally
Rooney those are my first three
recommendations and it doesn't matter
man woman young old it always works out
okay I have not read any of those three
you which one should you start with yeah
that's the question which one should I
start with and why oh boy
they're all so different it depends on
their mood little life well you can you
can interrogate my mood
then little life as if you are in the
mood to be kind of torn
apart not right now yeah so then I would
wait for that one that one that one will
take it takes it's almost like a hijack
I'm open to that yeah it's like it's an
emotional hijack you will disappear I'm
open to that just not right now
conversations with friends is the most
accurate depiction
of what it's like to be I don't know
this for sure but I just being like what
I think of what it means to sort of be
in a feminine State of Mind in your 20s
mhm it is just crystal clear and
Brilliant writing MH of the emotions of
what it's like to be young like and so I
just think for anyone who has ever been
Young when you read it it takes you it
takes you back there and takes it takes
over everything so I think that one and
you'll tear through it in a day and a
half because you won't be able to stop
secret history is if you just want great
writing and feel like you're in a
different world because Donna takes her
10 years to meticulously create a world
that the characters feel so real that
you're there so if you're just ready to
go somewhere else and disappear for a
while but without the emotional
hijacking you go to Donna tart emot if
you want to be emotionally like thrown
into a well honey and if you want to
just have the equivalent of a Taylor
Swift album in Pros that is much more
articulate you go to to Sally Rooney
conversation Perfect all right where
should we go next now I'm enjoying this
game because as we flip these over we
get to get to fewer and fewer options
these three interrelated are going to
all go together okay so I'll just we've
got two yellows which are changed mind
about cross collar
dating not sure what that is hookups
suspect I know what that is Couple's
language maybe we should start with
cross collar dating then cuz that's sort
of the the unlocking key have you never
heard this term I've never heard this
term I know what a cross collar throw is
in Judo but I'm guessing this is
unrelated cross collar dating is that
like white collar Blue Collar yes I'm
guessing yes yes yes it's and it's been
popular now I've just seen it a lot a
lot of columns about this and and things
like that which is also why when I
thought when Taylor started dating
Travis I'm like they're going to last
forever cuz they just will now watch
I'll have to eat my
words but it's similar to what happened
to me which was I lived in New York for
22 years I dated every lawyer accountant
investment banker out there like I went
through it all yeah and it always felt
like two clouds in the sky and no one on
earth like we were doing jobs that a
monkey would not understand like could
you explain your job to a monkey no
neither of us like oh I write wasn't
going to work yeah you
know so then when I met who literally
like is just in the earth he can tell
you when it's going to rain it was just
such a a match of someone
who has Earth Energy and someone who has
Sky energy cuz in Hindu that's the
balance it's not masculine feminine it's
not male female it's Sky energy and
Earth Energy I'm ashamed and astonished
I've never heard this before okay so
it's that's the balance you're looking
for and I'm all Sky I'm all what they
call shui which is thunder and lightning
you know that's me so I need somebody
who's like the guy on the ground holding
the kite before it flies on you know and
so I just think of like what was I doing
I should have known from the start and I
think I started to sense it as time went
on that I I needed to be with someone
Ultra grounded and so that's why I think
cross color dating works because also
you're not in each
other's space there's no competition
you're not competing for the
same thing you're not measuring each
other against maybe you also have
different Neurosis that's it which is
probably good yeah he's thinking about
all every one of nurses is about does he
have enough money to sell this group of
Cals for that you know like m and I'm
like I'm sure it's
fine that's my reaction to everything
I'm sure it's fine but I can't relate
other than be supportive and that's you
know when he comes to watch me do the
dance in Charleston he's just
like this is a lot not sure what this is
but you do
this
100% he calls it the dance of the red
shoes as a metaphor in general he's like
he's off doing his Dance of the red
shoes we'll see him when he's done and
that could be anything you know so I
think that's what it is you know and
whatever I see like two lawyers together
I'm like I don't know who's going to you
know M I don't know so yeah something
worth looking at all right today I
learned cross color
dating and now well actually look I'll
ask a self- serving question so I'm I'm
back on on the singles field as you know
we've talked about this
privately so what would that potentially
mean for me is is it more a set of
characteristics is it profession I mean
I have definitely this is not exactly
the same but I have had
enough perhaps tiptoeing around this to
realize like probably not a good idea
for me to be with another writer you
know what I mean like I've taken that
parking spot yeah I think that one is
enough agree I think it's as simple as
it's not so much the color it's about
the intensity of the commitment to what
it is so for instance I'm so committed
to my writing career and the
entrepreneurship of my life that it is
such a huge part of what I do that you
want to find somebody who has that same
commitment to what they do that is in a
completely different space so that's why
I look at like Taylor and Travis Kelce
because she is the most famous pop star
in the world she's always in the number
one position what man is ever going to
be able to have that same level
intensity but football player playing in
the same stadium in front of the same
amount of people and she has to be there
rooting for them it's perfect it's like
you're each doing your your thing it's
yours it's not the other person's but
the other person is there to cheerlead
and I think that to me is the perfect
recipe of where I think sometimes when
you have like even if it's an investment
banker and a lawyer there's something
similar about it but if you can find
something that's really different so
that you can just just relax and be a
cheerleader and feel almost humble like
coaches basketball and when I go watch
the games it's just fun to watch him
coach basketball because it has nothing
to do with my existence I have nothing I
didn't know that part you must love that
I'm just thinking of you with the
tutoring and also tennis background I
love it and he comes to me with all his
you know this kid this what do I say to
this kid this and I'm just like always
asking him questions I love it it's just
it's my favorite thing I'm always asking
more questions about what's happening
with the drama behind the scenes you
know
I'm still thinking of the dance of the
red shoes I may use that with you that's
great all right where should we go
hookups or couples's language well
couples language is a really quick one
but I think it's really interesting that
with couples I feel like every couple
this is in the Absurd category just so
people know because I thought it was
just us we have our own language at
times like words we make up and things
that we have that no one else would
understand and it's almost like animals
like we just came up with our own little
like barks and things and
repeated phrases and repeated thoughts
that are just ours and then I talked to
other couples and they have it too and I
was talking to a friend about this where
he's like you know him and his partner
instead of saying the word program they
used to use like a British accent for it
and say program or something you know
and and that was how they always said it
then you know they broke up and then the
new partner heard about this
somehow and started using it and he felt
this like irrational sense of like anger
like aversion to yeah yeah because it's
somebody else's language and I thought
that's when I thought oh no this is a
real thing this is like somehow in our
DNA to create this private language with
our other person like and I have a
million of them but like we use the word
malink a lot malink malink to refer to
something that is on its way to being
totally [__] but has not gotten there
it's it's circling the
drain is this an adjective or a noun
like it's it is a malink or it is minky
it's an adjective adjective so we use we
use that a lot a person could be minky a
dish that we're trying to cook could be
M so like it just comes up and so like
we have maybe a hundred of these kind of
words you know nicknames and things and
so it's just our own little private
language
hookups this is a a pretty simple one
but I you know in New York hookup called
was big
and I never really got into it I always
was more interested in in sort of
connections and things like that and
people are like but it's fun it's you
know so many hot guys I mean New York
has Austin is similar everywhere you go
everyone's like super model it's
annoying
but what the reason that it stopped me
was every time I was like okay you know
you could go hook up with that guy
whatever I used to think to myself well
what's the reason M and I realized that
it was cuz I was trying to extract
something from them they had this
hotness or this thing or this thing that
I felt that by hooking up with him I
would get right right and that's when I
started thinking about the term hookup
what is it hook it's like you're trying
to like you're trying to like literally
like a fish like hook them and like get
this thing there's no connection NE like
needed you're going to dispose of them
at some point you know it's a succubus
you're just going to lean over breathe
in their soul that's it and I thought to
myself and in my case it was obvious cuz
it felt like I was going after certain
kind of guys that had things that I I
wanted and I realized it was never cuz I
liked them it was cuz I wanted to be
them or I wanted this thing that they
had physically or something and it was
always like you just want to extract and
I thought that can't be good for your
soul I just thought that can't be good
because what's going to happen if you
mentally go through with it yes you're
going to go you're going to extract this
thing or try tot ract it you're going to
fail to extract it and they're going to
leave and you're still not going to have
it I mean New York as you described it
is just such a
hyperkinetic environment that I feel
like whether it's related to hookups or
alcohol or other like you need to have
some guard rails where I feel like that
environment will sort of Eat You Alive I
think it's funny because we can move to
one now that we're
here I lived there for 22 years and I
you know would go to Florida and go to
places that were much
slower to relax but I think with New
York and La what I realized is until
you're out of there for an extended
period of
time that's when you finally get to be
yourself because New York and la and
even Chicago and the biggest city of San
Francisco everything's so reactive
you're just it's too much stimulus to
ever process in a way where you're just
alone with your thoughts in a consistent
way way so it's not just vacation but on
a you know permanent basis and when I
moved to St Louis I didn't have any
friends there I was new to the city I
knew no one is still you know getting
used to it but it's quiet not much is
happening and it's for the first time in
my life it was just me and I felt like
in those 10 months I had to grow I got
it so you had a 10mon period where you
were there full-time yeah got it because
I was going to say the the astute listen
May note that you said I go every
weekend earlier I think it was right to
St Louis you tell me how what does your
Geographic split look like okay so I
moved to St Louis in end of January of
this year and then I go to New York
maybe three or four days a month and in
those three or four days when I first
started going I felt like I'm home like
thank
God and then each month each time I went
I started to dread it and dread it more
I was still seeing all my friends I was
getting to do all the fun stuff that I
get to do in New York whenever I go
there the restaurants the
this but I was just like I could feel
myself be like we're going to war like
that's what it feels like when you go
into the city again you know and I just
realized like especially for me where I
am at my stage where I want to commit to
my heart and the things I want to do and
connection and relationships especially
with this new set of tools that I have
post ketamine where I feel like I'm
finally getting to connect and be in the
moment and have fun and be present and
slow in terms of my experiences like in
New York it never would have happened
you know do you think you'll have an EB
and flow in that way you'll have a
seasonal relationship to that stuff do
you think there's a chance that you do
St Louis for a period and then you have
sort of a a city period and then a rural
period or do you think I think what I'm
realizing is I'm in the creative zone
now where like I'm done with school for
evil and fairy tales for a while I'm
making new work so for the next two
years that's really where I am is the
making new
work which involves also making new life
new partner new city it's a new chapter
totally it's a second act right it looks
nothing like my First Act First Act was
New York fairy tales I'm now doing
something totally different in St Louis
and on a goat farm so like new album
right so I don't know what will happen
what I'm done writing and it's time to
promote will it be dance with the red
shoes again let's go to New York and
dress of course it will be of course it
will be and it'll be I think it'll be
great I think it'll be great see you
have the goat farm goat farm St Louis
what is St Louis like as a city I
haven't spent any time there it's quiet
it's manageable it's a very like family
oriented City people whenever people are
like oh I just moved to St Louis it's to
be in near family usually most of the
time but you're not in
the outer reaches of the Brooks range in
Alaska like a flight from people you
have access to oh yeah there yeah yeah
everything's there restaurants are there
I just think it's a city that has a lot
of potential it reminds me a little bit
of like when I first started to come to
Austin eight or nine years ago I was
like oh this place is going to go crazy
one day when people find out what's here
yeah St Louis isn't quite at that level
like it's I feel like it's evolving but
there's a lot there where people are
going to be like weather's good people
are great food's good easy to get around
no tra it just feels like it's a sleepy
little city that people kind of gave up
on yeah but I wouldn't be surprised if
it has a a boom at some point it's the
opposite of a malinki is opposite of
mink or it is opposite of malink excuse
me did it
correctly it's opposite yeah there's a
lot to be said about St Louis so I'm
excit and also like I just haven't met
that many people so I'm excited to to
start you know making friends
mhm speaking of britishisms when you're
mentioning the shared language of
program program I have no idea dodgy
dodgy
allergies this is in the Absurd category
on the purple card this is a good one to
end on I tell everyone I'm allergic to
cranberries and eggplant mhm am I
allergic to cranberries and eggplant are
you I don't know I don't know but I've
been saying it for so
[Music]
long that I I'm like is it true so the
question is when we are allergic to
things and I think this gets to a bigger
like more profound question like
where did that start like I know that
once upon a time I thought cranberries
caused hives or something and then I ate
cranberries I don't know what this was
probably when I was like a teenager and
got like a bad case of hives and
therefore have told people ever since I
can't eat cranberries mhm but it was it
because it could be something else could
be something else right and so this
happens I think a lot with you know when
we were young I remember first having
like peanut butter and things like that
and having weird reactions to it being
like this makes me feel
weird but there was no option to stop
eating it there was
no don't eat the peanut butter it was
like we'll just keep giving you peanut
butter until one day your system gets
used to it so I was just thinking about
the fact that like the way that it's
easy to in your mind create these little
like zones of you know like I can't
touch eggplant no F zon Once Upon a Time
this thing happen and it makes you start
to question I don't know deeper no fly
zones you know so anyway that was
something that crossed my mind of like
at some point we need to test the nfly
zones and basically eat cranberry sauce
see what
happens small world for the record if
you working in a restaurant I tell you I
have an eggplant allergy it's because I
ate eggplant my whole life and then one
day boom anaphylaxis full-blown like
almost died in a restaurant in San
Francisco it's true and I went in that
wasn't step one step one was had this
dish had some whatever it was Swordfish
fine vegetables fine outside of eggplant
then I had the eggplant and my tongue
got really itchy and I was like huh
that's weird yeah feels like an allergic
reaction I've never had an allergic
reaction egg plan so being the genius
that I am and I'm saying that
sarcastically I was like well I'm going
to fores like an engineer I want to
figure out can I replicate the bug yeah
so I went back the next day Pro tip do
not do this if you have a mild allergic
reaction don't do what I'm about to
describe so I'm back and I was like well
I'll try it again and if my tongue gets
itchy I'll go have a slle testing but
that's not how allergic reactions work
yeah right like if you have one allergic
reaction that is minor it can suddenly
step function up to something very
serious and that's exactly what happened
so I ate the exact same dish I had the
allergic reaction but this time my
throat closed down to like the size of a
coffee straw it's and it was rush hour
it was in the mission in certain part of
the mission in San Francisco where there
was absolutely no possibility that an
ambulance was going to get to me within
30 minutes yeah no Bodega or anything
nearby because I asked the staff I was
like do you have any benad dril and they
were like no do you have an EpiPen no
and I was like [__] of all the dumb
things that I've done in my life this is
what's going to kill me really yeah and
I just sat there that was all I could do
and I was like well freaking out isn't
going to do anything and I was like I
guess I'm just going to have to tr to
breathe very calmly and it's slowly and
I passed through it therefore I've not
had much iplant now I will say I went
and had extensive extensive allergy
testing done at Stanford with all these
top docks and at least with the species
of eggplant that they used for their
various sampling and testing no allergy
no demonstrable allergy to
eggplant which raises a bunch of
questions now one option is it's a
different species of eggplant okay
possibly who knows yeah the other which
is scarier which a very well-known
friend and Tech founder who people would
recognize brought up was maybe it is a
pesticide that you are unable to
identify but that is so psychologically
terrifying yes yes yes for me Toom play
that I've doubled down on the eggplant
see this is what and this is why
dogology came to my mind because it's
like at least I can avoid eggplant right
to me when I say dodgy what I mean is
mental allergies in the sense of
the allergy is compounded sometimes by
this extra Force so like when I was on a
plane and they called out okay someone
has a peanut allergy therefore were're
not serving peanuts or cashews or
whatever it was everyone was like oh
okay little grumbling but whatever next
plane they were like someone has an
alcohol allergy we are not serving
alcohol it was like Saigon like
everyone
M everyone's Racing for the last
helicopter do you mean like to get off
that plane so it was a sudden thing of
we have to take allergy seriously but
then this one we're not taking seriously
because you know like so it's it was it
just comes to me sometimes when I think
it's worth looking at sort of the mental
stress around the allergy you know I
agree also just asking the 30,000 foot
question which I'm sure very confident
qualified people have examined but what
is going on with all of these well that
was a question allergies that's what I
was thinking to myself like when I was
young I definitely think I had a penut
allergy and I think got used to the
discomfort and to the point where the
body was finally like all right I guess
this is we're doing this and just I
guess got used to it and I don't think
that was necessarily the right way to to
handle it but that's what happened
before and now it's different you know
it is interesting to see on the farm
none of the kids all the nephews nobody
has allergies there's something about
that like the farm so much going on that
interesting first thing I do with the
baby put her in the cow pen
put into the farm you go all right
there's one more thing I can see over
there which is one remaining name
remaining maybe more than one no there's
one that that is worth talking about
which is the daughter of a friend who
introduced us how I first met you I met
you through Brian cman that creator of
billions and I have an ey completely
independent of the fact that you know
obviously I I know her and I've seen her
grow up I have my eye on his daughter
Anna who is 23 and standup comedian and
writer because she is
so good he has very talented skilled
kids I tutored both of
them all right I did know I did no work
with either take his customer
15% I in terms of working with either of
them there was nothing to be done these
kids came fully
formed 100% just sat there talked to the
family and had family dinners and
somehow got paid for it I felt like they
were the most incredible kids Sam is the
older one and will probably be president
someday and Anna is just she reminds me
of do you know Miranda July I do not
great name though yeah she is in the
early 2000 late 90s which is this very
prolific and still writes
and great comedy great just versatile at
everything involving writing and
Performing and that's Anna I feel like
she can write she can do standup she can
write novels it's just the voice is so
sharp and interesting and mature that at
at 23 that I just I'm like what's going
to happen so I feel like she's one to
one to keep an eye on to keep an eye on
you know I just think sometimes when I I
feel like when I was growing up people
were like okay we don't know what he's
going to do but he'll do something
interesting cuz I was just kind of you
know MH off doing my dance with the red
shoes and I feel like and uhuh I feel
like the same like something interesting
is going to happen something interesting
is going to happen so I have my eye on
her so it's good to end on on somebody
young up and that's where I think my
brain always is I'm looking at youth for
talent ambition and most of all
commitment you know what do you think
Brian and his wife have done to Foster
some of that question this could be
nature versus nurture who knows maybe
they're just thoroughbreads came from
good stock but I suspect there's more to
it probably a little bit certainly at
the very least what do you think I think
they encourag their ideas I just feel
like when they had ideas it was like it
almost felt like an improv house where
if one was like I think I should do this
it would be like yes and like everything
was like yes
no no shooting down ideas it was just go
with it you know Neil degress Tyson
talks about how he's like to me the
ideal parent sees a kid reaching for an
egg on the table and the kid's going to
grab the like a toddler it's and he's
like you stop that kid from dropping the
egg cuz you're afraid of the mess and
wasting 40 cents on an egg you're going
to lose that toddler seeing this thing
explode and leak three different
substances and a yoke and a thing and a
how did that thing turn into that and
all of a sudden you have a scientist in
a 3-year-old you know what else can I
draw
and see what's going to happen and so
he's like that's it it's just saying yes
and not giving too much Direction you
know and that's what that's why I said
about the kid making the bed the kid
coming to things on his own terms don't
comment let them evolve you know just
look at the photo no need to add your
two cents underneath you know what I
mean I do so what fun this is this has
been so much fun
is there anything else you would like
to mention anything you'd like to point
people to any closing comments anything
at all that you it's just so fun to get
to have a a conversation with such a
deep thinker and to be able to play
around you know what I mean like you
never get to do this in real life so I
feel like getting to do this is an honor
and I'm just very thankful that you had
me ah what a pleasure so fun I'm looking
forward to continuing a dinner where can
people find you online best place to
find me is my website Som chain.com s
oan c h a i
n.com and then I don't use Twitter
anymore so Instagram's probably where
you know I see messages and things like
that so s andc on Instagram s andc on
Instagram we'll link to everything in
the show notes folks so you can find
that at tim. Blog podcast and just
search s there there will not be an
overwhelming number of of entries s o M
A an and until next time as always be a
bit Kinder than is necessary not only to
other people but to
yourself and thanks for tuning in
everybody talk to you
soon